What is it that makes a person a hero? Is
it a trait that you’re born with; something
you can inherit, passed down from generation to
generation? Is someone still a hero if they never
save a life, but improve the lives of the people
that matter to them? Do you really need a magic
hammer, an enchanted suit of armor, or a tragic
origin story in order to become a hero, or can
you still be heroic as an ordinary, everyday
person, through the simplest of kind deeds?
Maybe it only takes a few moments in a lifetime to
be a hero, moments when you are given the chance
to overcome adversity or conquer a personal flaw.
Perhaps learning how to deal with defeat and get
back up after, rather than learning how to never
be defeated, is the essence of heroism. We can all
be heroes, every single one of us, and in a way,
we already are. Everyone is the hero of their own
story, and if you want any further proof of that,
then maybe you should take a look inside SCP-1230.
An unassuming book is presented to you, its hard
cover is dark green, but other than that there is
absolutely nothing remarkable about it that you
can notice. But little do you know, this book
that you hold in your hands is none other than
SCP-1230. So, what’s inside? Surely it must be an
important anomalous artifact if the SCP Foundation
has an interest in it. Perhaps it’s filled with
ancient spells, or a mathematical formula to
calculate the exact mass of the fabric of reality?
No, if you’re expecting every page
to be full, you’d be disappointed.
In fact, only the first page you open in
the book will have anything written on it,
the rest will appear blank. And this can
change depending on which page you open first,
resetting every time the book is closed again.
However, the phrase you will find written on
that page will always stay the same. When opening
SCP-1230, you will see the words “A hero is born.”
What happens after you read those words? Well,
not much, at least not right away. In fact,
you won’t notice any active effects after reading
SCP-1230 for quite some time. Until that is, you
fall asleep, and as you sleep, you begin to dream.
Now, most dreams are pretty disjointed, sometimes
fragments of memories or your deepest, most random
thoughts. Of course, other times it’s a fear,
a long-held and deep-rooted phobia or
manifestation of anxiety brought to the
surface for a while in the form of a nightmare,
only to be forgotten by the time you’ve woken
up. Perhaps that’s why so many people look
for the deeper meaning to their dreams,
to get a better understanding of themselves.
But this dream is different, far more vivid
and memorable, with a meaning that is
a lot easier to discern. In this dream,
you find yourself as the hero of your own story,
the protagonist of a fantastical adventure.
It’s more than an ordinary dream, it looks,
sounds, smells, feels as real as the ordinary
world you know. You will find yourself at the
center of a fantasy world, where you are the
hero destined to aid this troubled land, to
bring peace, and save the world. The fantasy
you find yourself in is different depending
on who you are, it’s a dreamscape that has
been tailor-made for your enjoyment, and your epic
quest awaits on the path laid out in front of you.
But where do these bespoke fantasy adventures come
from? Does the SCP-1230 book itself bestow these
dreams on a reader, or is there some other force
at play that creates worlds where the dreamer is
the hero? Well, actually yes, there is, and
his name is The Book Keeper, or SCP-1230-1.
He looks exactly as you would imagine him
to, an old man adorned in a dark green cloak,
with a long beard, sometimes appearing
to dreamers in order to guide them.
Picture Gandalf from the Lord of the Rings
books, but instead of ‘the grey’ or ‘the white’,
the Book Keeper is Gandalf the Green. In every
dream caused by SCP-1230, the Book Keeper appears
as the personification of the book itself, often
aiding dreamers, willingly offering them counsel,
guidance, and help on their fantastical quests.
In an experiment to test the range of SCP-1230’s
anomalous properties, an SCP Foundation
researcher opened the book and then boarded
a domestic flight, spending the night in a hotel
in his hometown. Even miles away from the book,
the researcher still experienced a
fantastical dream and during this dream,
he was approached by SCP-1230-1. The Book Keeper
was happy to explain the workings of the book,
describing how SCP-1230 implanted a dream in the
reader’s subconscious mind from the moment they
saw the phrase “A hero is born” on the page.
He claimed that he was the sole being with
the ability to manipulate what he described as
“fantasy scapes”, and that he enjoyed doing this,
aiming to sculpt these fantastical dreams in such
a way that the dreamer experiencing them would get
the most enjoyment out of being the hero of
their own story. Thanks to the Book Keeper,
the length of the dreams vary. They could
be quick, only lasting forty-five seconds
or seem to last as long as two hundred years
from the dreamer’s point of view. However,
in the real world, the person experiencing the
Book Keeper’s fantasy scape would only actually
be asleep for an average duration of time.
SCP-1230 only takes effect on living beings
with the capacity for imagination. In other
words, only human beings are affected by the book
and able to enter their own bespoke fantasy.
When the SCP Foundation attempted to use a
mechanical arm to open SCP-1230, the pages
remained blank, leading the Book Keeper to
explain to a subsequent dreamer that only beings
who can dream may find the phrase “A hero is born”
within. Most animals or any machines that view
the book will not experience its effects at all.
So, what can a person do within the fantasy
scapes of these dreams? Is it an open sandbox
to do anything and everything you can think of,
or do these fantastical realms have their own
rules? Well, for a start, they seem to be
completely safe spaces. During testing,
the Foundation conducted a number of experiments
that involved getting members of D Class personnel
to read SCP-1230 and test the limitations of the
dream worlds the Book Keeper created for them.
Why use D Class personnel to test out
something seemingly as harmless as SCP-1230?
Because the Foundation wanted to know if
a person could die in one of these dreams.
One test involved ordering a D Class to
immediately find a way to terminate himself
once he found himself inside the dream world.
He awakened after only forty-five seconds of
being asleep, and described being at the peak of
a volcano called “The Ashen Spire.” Apparently,
within the dream, this test subject had been sent
on a quest to recover a sword known as “Caladius,
the Blessed Blade.” He said these names had
come to him as if he had known them all along.
Following the Foundation’s orders,
the D Class attempted to throw himself
into the volcano before him, only to wake
up moments later after feeling intense heat,
but suffering no adverse
effects in the real world.
During the following experiment, another D Class
was told to try and injure himself in the fantasy
scape, but not a fatal injury. This subject awoke
after six hours of sleep, feeling a numbed pain in
the same place he had attempted to harm himself,
but this sensation was never intense, in fact, it
was barely noticeable. In his dream, the D Class
said that he had conversed with the Book Keeper,
who had shown concern that the man was trying
to cause himself injury but thanked him for
not terminating himself immediately like the
“other rude fellow” that had preceded him.
So, all of this sounds pretty great, right? A book
that lets someone live out a fantasy adventure
in which they are the hero of their own bespoke
story. What could possibly be the downside? Well,
the downside is this: What if someone
preferred their fantasy to the real world?
Now comes the unfortunate story of a
Professor working for the SCP Foundation,
a lifelong fan of tabletop roleplaying games like
Dungeons & Dragons. The Professor filed a request
for access to SCP-1230, and it was granted. He
was apparently shaking with pure excitement.
After reading “A hero is born” in the book, he
didn’t even wait until later to go to sleep,
instead opting to doze off right then
and there at the desk where he’d read it.
After the Professor had spent fifteen
entire hours asleep, concern had begun to
spread among the other researchers. He remained
sleeping, living out his own fantasy adventure,
for a further nine hours, spending a total of
twenty four hours in the dream world that the Book
Keeper had made for him. When the Professor awoke,
he appeared to look around the room confused,
unsure of where he was when approached
by the Foundation’s security personnel.
Medical staff examined him
and explained where he was,
after which the Professor seemed to regain
his memory. After being reminded who he was,
the Professor excused himself to the restroom.
He didn’t emerge, and fifteen minutes later a
member of the medical team went to check on him.
Sadly, the Professor was dead. Scribbled on the
nearby bathroom wall was one simple phrase,
his last words: “I can’t go back to this.”
Attempting to immediately use SCP-1230
and make contact with the Book Keeper,
another doctor tried to find the “A hero is
born” phrase within the pages of the book.
However, instead, the pages were soaking wet,
and on every single page, the same message:
“I am so sorry. I never intended for this to
happen. I just wanted to make people happy.”
For three weeks the book stayed like this until
the same doctor placed a sticky note inside
SCP-1230 that said “I’d like to
talk to you, if that’s alright.”
That night, the doctor fell asleep and dreamt
of being in a dark void. There was only one
source of light in the endless darkness, a
streetlamp, under which he found the Book Keeper,
sat in a puddle. The old bearded man was sobbing
uncontrollably, his cloak soaking wet with his
tears. He explained, through his overwhelming
sadness, what had happened to the Professor:
“He had such an active imagination! I was able to
create a vast and beautiful universe for him and
it was obvious that he had wanted a life like that
for so long. He conquered foul beasts and rescued
princesses… He built kingdoms and even raised a
family… but he never wanted to leave. He delved so
far into his fantasy world that I soon realized
he preferred his dream over the real world.
I reminded him that this was all merely an
illusion, but he wouldn’t listen to me. He
stated that if he was ever forced to leave,
he would immediately end his life. I tried
to keep him happy for as long as I could…”
The Book Keeper revealed that,
from the Professor’s point of view, the fantasy
life he had lived lasted two hundred years.
As much as the old man had tried to hold on and
keep the Professor happy for as long as possible,
eventually, he had to release him from the fantasy
scape. And, as a result, the Professor had ended
his own life rather than return to reality.
SCP-1230 resumed its normal function a few
days later, after the doctor left another note
between the pages, offering some friendly advice
to the Book Keeper. Now, it sits quietly on a
bookshelf in the Site 12 library, surrounded
by fictional novels, the perfect material to
inspire more fantasy scapes in the future.
We all like to dream that we’re the heroes
of our own stories. But, to quote the Book
Keeper himself, “As sweet as dreams may
be, eventually we all have to wake up.”
Now go check out “SCP-1762 - Where
The Dragons Went” and “SCP-348 - A
Gift from Dad” for more anomalies that
are sure to tug at your heart strings.